Audrey Hale slowly pulls into the
parking lot of Covenant School the
shooter fires through a locked glass
door to gain entry in combat gear armed
with one assault rifle and toting
another hail wanders the halls of the
Christian School looking for victims
it's a tale of horror told through the
surveillance footage released by
Nashville police officers badge cameras
capture the response police get the call
at 10 13 shots fired they're upstairs
learning the lessons of the 2022 Uvalde
Texas school shooting where police
wasted precious minutes as a gunman
fired on children
let's go
let's go act fast
Metro Police room by room is fire alarm
sound off the officers clear the first
floor
they rushed toward the sound of gunfire
and close in
[Music]
with the attacker a former student down
soon to be declared dead it's over at 10
27 a.m 14 minutes after police received
the call in that time Hale has gunned
down three nine-year-old students and
three staffers in their 60s
police say Hale had amassed an Arsenal
we've determined that Audrey about seven
firearms from five different uh local
gun stores here legally
two were assault weapons President Joe
Biden who fought for a federal assault
weapons ban that Congress passed in 1994
only to watch it expire 10 years later
once again calls for another band of the
weapons hale used to kill
as a nation we hold these families more
than our prayers
we owe them action
you know we have to do more to stop this
gun violence or ripping communities
apart ripping apart the soul of this
nation
protect our children so they learn how
to read rights that a Duck and Cover in
a classroom but there is almost no
chance of passing another ban this is
the 2021 Christmas card picture the
congressman who represents the Nashville
district where it all happened Andy
ogles posing with his family bearing
assault weapons a portrait of
intransigence in the effort to change
gun laws in America John hendren Al
Jazeera